les jeunes et jolies ça s'est bien passé
pour moi pas trop mal métier c'est pas
facile enfin je crois que je me suis
sorti quand même
10 et je te vends du ballon mais je sais
pas que j'ai mis l'argent parce que
j'étais à la boutique ensuite y répondre
il m'a demandé une sucette alors je suis
revenue j'ai mis leurs gentils on leur
bord et puis alors à ce moment là parce
que c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
julie sait que c'est très gentil de nous
avaient à remplacer sabrina et moi enfin
en gros tout s'est bien passé oui très
bien mais tu sais que j'ai toujours pas
vu l'arrivée quasi murs ses droits en
déçu que ça m'irrite à la
lettre ses murs
à bonjour ça va qu'est-ce que vous êtes
là ça donne l'idée de faire un jeu c'est
pas du casino n'ont pas fait rien alors
jean chercheurs et je vous le dis je lis
ou et démons garde mes bouquins mais tu
crois pas qu'il faudra bien qu'on essaie
de chercher l'argent parce que je
voudrais surtout pas que tu crois que
j'ai les jolies jules je vis je t'en
prie c'est pas grave aucune importance
à la
barre qu'elle veut
c'est vraiment chaud là où tu m'écoutes
qu'est ce que c'est or un joli bonjour
je suis bien content de te voir ces
guignols et formidable lauriad dans ton
petit numéro là je le pense aussi à
droite sans
merci merci à kazimiya ça y est ça y est
ça y est j'ai trouvé mon jeu on va faire
une comptine êtes d'accord jouez avec
nous casini ont fait une comptine chic
alors j'attends les conti la danse et la
musique
ouais
t'as la tap tap tap tap à la papa kazim
kazim à venir avant la musique on
s'occupe des paroles d'accord mais on
appelle les enfants des enfants il y en
a quelques uns qui mène avec moi pas
tout ça parce que vous êtes beaucoup 3
vendredi est ce que je peux me réjouir
avec vous parce que passer son temps à
chercher l'argent c'est pas on va jouer
coûte julie pour la dernière fois je dis
que l'argent on verra ça tout à l'heure
on leur tendre un vaste programme
l'un des papiers et crayon et je note
tout alors je vous explique ce que c'est
une comptine exécuté bien y arriver on
m'écoute vous connaissez un deux trois
nous irons aux lois quatre cinq six pays
à des cerises connaissait ça
là on va y jouer en partant de 1 jusqu'à
10 et cette comptine s'appellera si
j'étais zain si on est deux dire si
j'étais zain vous me donnez un mot qui
rime avec un après avec 2 3 4 5 6 tc
super à ces compris bon alors que prince
si j'étais un filet vous le sentirez le
thème harwich 6000 points si j'étais
jeune je sentirai le destin c'est bon si
j'étais de jean-françois
suis gt2
je mangerai 2e arrêt
alors si on était trois sangliers y
croire
si on était froid
carole
alors si on était 3 par exemple on
enchaîne une loi sur les 3 on mangera
des noix ont fait mentir et si on était
quasiment maintenant enfin ces
libérations étaient quatre en forêt du
théâtre si on était cartes aux frais du
théâtre comme si on était cinq la télé
j'en étais
500 et essayent julie tu as une idée on
chanterait une complète je chanterai une
complète voilà si on était cinq ans
chantera une complète si on était six
carole
cyr a qui trouvent à vous le dites je
dit carole
vas-y fais des plans sociaux en manger
des saucisses à les cracks qu'est-ce
qu'il est mort
si on était six homogène et saucisses si
on était certain si on était sept on
mangera les frites non ça n'appartient
pas aux régionales et c'est eh bien on
mangeait tout ça dans une assiette un
beso 6e le terrain fut que ce qu'on
avait vu si on était huit ou chercher
au moins 18
si on était neuf qu'elle aimait nous
écoute je cherche du feu sur l'homme
recherché mais j'ai mille casimir gens
alors j'en étais nord julie tu as une
idée pour s'habiller tout en off on
servirait tout un oeuf ouais ouais alors
maintenant le dernier vous précipiter là
le premier qui me répond si on était dix
sept et dix
non c'est pas d'os
se fait moi je trouve rien casimir sur
les métiers et pis on en serait
l'actrice ava c'est un bien très bien
que
tout ça c'était plus approximatif ouais
mais on va ça fait rien ça passe quand
même et vos cheveux vous avez fait aussi
une comptine parfait comme la lyre et
après en attendant julie nous lie c'est
quand même faire résilier si je suis je
sens le tas si on met deux je mange des
oeufs si on est roi où manquent des noix
si on l'est car on fait du théâtre
si on est cinq ont chanté une contrainte
si on est 6 au 10 octobre la 5e manche
des assiettes si on est huit orange 2 si
on est neuf pour sa ville qui donnent là
si on est dix dans le soir
si on met un
sévère 2
ac il fait beau
je me sens très bien
rien de tel qu'une petite promenade dans
les bois pour vous mettre en forme j'ai
une faim
julie
julie j'ai très faim ouvre-moi
julie ouvrant c'est moi je gfa julie
celui-là
comment as tu fait pour sortir
de quoi parles-tu comment as tu fait
pour sortir sans que je te vois je ne
suis pas sûr que ce n'était pas dans mon
kiosque au mais je comprends pas
normalement tu es tous les jours dans
mon kiosque à cette heure-là mais
aujourd'hui n'est pas un jour comme les
autres tu n'as rien remarqué remarquez
qu est-ce qu il y a qu est ce qui se
passe arrête de tourner comme ça regarde
tout on est je n'ai pas donné excuse moi
sur le kiosque alors sur le kiosque
ah oui je n'ai pas vu c'est joli comme
en reste que tu l'a accroché mayan moque
elle est accrochée là je ne comprends
pas j'ai fait le tour du kiosque elle
savait rien remarqué que c'est normal tu
l'avais sous le nez je n'ai pas donné
d'accord disons que tu étais trop près
pour la voir pourquoi trop près pas
parce que tu ne pouvais saisir que des
détails insignifiants pour voir
l'ensemble de la fiche il faut se
reculer
ah oui c'est vrai oui je vends beaucoup
mieux la fiche lorsque je suis un peu
loin et qu'est ce que tu vois je
j'avais oublié de la lire oui attend
aujourd'hui leçons de cuisine par julie
wormee dable j'ai justement une de ses
fins alors qu'est ce que tu vas cuisiner
vigato un gâteau tricoire formidable
laisse moi deviner c'est une tarte aux
cerises avec des oignons certainement
pas
alors un gâteau au chocolat avec des
anchois encore moins
alors je donne ma langue au chat ben tu
vas voir les enfants venez allégé carole
j'ai apporté pour faire un gâteau
du sucre
du beurre
des oeufs
et de la farine et il n'y a pas de
mayonnaise ni d'escargots ça ne fait pas
partie mars est
alors ton gâteau va être très mauvais
attends moi je vais te montrer comment
on prépare un excellent gâteau
voilà
je vais vous préparer un gâteau
formidable
geslin du sucre de la farine
de la confiture
et ce nu
du fromage
détriment
du saucisson
et doolaeghe robin écoute casimir arrête
parce que moi j'ai la tête qui tourne je
vais donner ma leçon de cuisine en os
temps tu vas faire ton gâteau et on
verra quel est le meilleur préparé un
gâteau formidable alors voilà les
enfants ont mais en quantités égales le
sucre le beurre les oeufs et la farine
on commence par les eaux
on met le jaune
à vous ment garder bien pour pouvoir le
faire chez vous
voilà on met 4e parce que chaque oeuf
pèse environ 60 grammes alors ça fait
environ 250 g 4 e g 250 g de sucre de
beurre et de farine
après on met le sucre
à vous retenez bien et vous chez vous
aussi le sucre
et les jaunes on les mélange bias
quand ils sont bien mélanger on ajoute
la farine
c'est le gâteau le plus sam ça s'appelle
un 4/4 parce qu'il ya une quantité égale
de chaque ingrédient
la farine
et le beurre mélangez un peu encore la
farine et le beurre on le met petit à
petit en ou là là je vais le mettre
bien amour pour qui ce mélange plus
facilement
voilà
et on mélange tout ça jusqu'à obtenir
une pâte bien homogène
après avoir mélangé d'ailleurs avec la
cuillère c'est plus facile une fois
qu'on obtient une patate de plus
mélangé de prendre les mains
voila quand les geôles le sucre et la
farine sont bien amalgamer on bat les
blancs en neige on met un petit peu de
sel pour qu'ils montrent mieux
voilà alors quand les blancs sont battus
en neige on les ajoute à la pâte
on re mélange tout
il s'assoit nouveau bien homogène
et voilà ça va être prêt à cuire
qu'est ce que c'est 1 4 k il ne reste
plus qu'à le faire cuire et le cas ça va
encore 2 et
balla
bien alors il ne reste plus qu'a rappelé
aussi sont maintenant bon bah tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure
les enfants venaient le gâteau est cuit
vous venez le goûter aux enfants venez
goûter le meilleur des gâteaux
site avec ton mélange de tout à l'heure
que tu as fait ça ouais et alors ça
c'est incroyable alors mais non c'est
normal puisque je suis le meilleur des
pâtissiers
salut tiens mais mais qu'est ce qui se
passe mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
casimir et m'en viens de faire un
concours de pâtisserie où il regarde ce
qu'il est arrivé à faire avec de la
farine du beurre de l'aïe oui un du
gruyère de la confiture de framboises
alors et du saucisson bon mais ça doit
être est mangeable bon moi je ne trouve
pas hormis d'armes et toi je suis sûr
que tu vas adorer non mais tu vas
casimir je préfére goûter le gâteau de
julie
une bonne part
vous prendre et il est très facile à
faire j'espère que vous avez retenu la
recette aurait bien maintenant outre le
moins de cadeaux bien mais juste un
petit morceau 1 par curiosité attention
il ya aussi du piment de jean guy moreau
et baal osé
alors
il est très beau
les meilleurs d2 albi j'ai gagné ce film
est fière car tu m'as l'air bien eu des
paroles je viens de gagner le concours
de gâteaux le concours de gâteaux
maintenant moi je racontais le pâtissier
et s'il me demandait de torrents m la
facture du gâteau à la crème que tu te
fais livrer toute alerte ya par exemple
mais alors tu as triché casimir
quasiment
[Musique]